welcome to 8701
um my name is marcus clutter i'm going
to be your instructor for this class
um this class is taught in an inverted
classroom or flipped classroom
environment
so this is the very first of a large
number of small
short videos which goes to the contents
of slides i prepared
you know for this first slide it's not
necessary that you even watch the video
because they should explain themselves
and i will not give you too much
additional information
as we go deeper into the content that's
not quite the case
and that might be useful for you to you
know watch the videos
uh learn stop um record a number of
questions
so some of the problems which i post on
this on the slides and so on
so this is the very first one and the
idea of this
set of slides is to just give you a
quick overview
of what to expect for this class
the first thing we look at is a calendar
for the fall semester
the summer ended much more quickly than
we were all hoping for
um the weather is still very nice out
there but fall is coming
uh so tuesday september 1st we'll meet
and greet
in the first session um that session is
really just meant for
you know an overview of the course
organization and so on
so this kind of information as i give in
this video will be very briefly covered
on that tuesday as well
as you can see from the calendar we meet
tuesday and thursday
um the the meeting or the recitation
starts at 1 30 pm
i aim for one hour in each of those
meetings but we can stay a little longer
if
even half an hour longer if there's open
questions or
need for discussion this semester will
give us a few holidays along the way
there's columbus day where tuesday is a
student holiday
i will not have a recitation on election
day i want you to focus on the election
and i will focus on it myself
um and then there is a week of
thanksgiving where we will not have
any any meeting any class during that
week
you can also see that there is a number
of pieces every second week we'll post a
pset and i'll give you about two weeks
to respond to that pset more on how we
evaluate in this class
in a different recording um just to say
here already that
there is going to be two all exams uh
towards the middle of the
semester and towards the end um very
short
uh little test 15 minutes per student i
will set up individual
meetings to um to go over this
um and then there's friday as an office
hour i haven't specified the time for
this yet
i'll send you a doodle poll and we'll
find the time which works for most of
you
on a friday friday afternoon or friday
morning
um this class doesn't have a final
so it basically ends with the last day
of class which is
um with this oral exams on in the week
in the 15th week's
15th week of this class
looking a little bit into the content um
you know the first week is really on
introduction and some historic remarks
we talk about
a relativistic kinematics and then we go
along
uh the outline as given in one of our
textbooks um
again textbooks are being discussed yet
in a different
short presentation but i'll really
follow along this textbook
but not stick too much to
you know only the content of that
textbook and i will supplement the
information and
using other textbooks as well
specifically when it comes to
some of the problems um and discussions
which come along
you can see that we'll start with
particle physics uh talk about quark
leptons and interactions
we'll talk about in how this fits in a
theoretical
way with invariance principle and
conversation laws and we'll look at
scattering and then qcd
before we go into weak interaction and
from there on we built the standard
model
with the electro weak interaction the
hex mechanism
so week 8 then or the end of week it
will give us a break
where we then start talking about
nuclear physics
you know this order of talking about
particle physics and then nuclear
physics
makes a lot of sense to me um it doesn't
make sense in historic in the
torah context because nuclear physics
ideas were developed before
the standard model for example was
developed but in order to fully
appreciate nuclear physics it's useful
to have introduced
basic interactions and therefore this is
the reason for this
for this order and then we try to bring
in
experimental methods with accelerators
colliding beams
um and experimental methods on how
particles interact with matter and
detectors
um again in in this in this uh schedule
thanksgiving thanksgiving week is off
and we'll use
the last remaining week to discuss
physics beyond the standard model and
the
connection to cosmology i said in the
title um the schedule will be tuned
i very much
expect that we have a little bit
slippage in this but there is some room
at the end to make sure that we don't
overrun
and that i don't give you too much to
learn to reach to watch movies
or you know do presets as we go week per
week
this is it for this first recording um
you know as always you can reach out and
ask any any sort of question either
during the recitation
office hours or separate emails